In West Africa, where I live,
there are 60 million smallholder farmers.
Smallholder farmers are the largest group
of people living
on less than two dollars a day.
Many go hungry each year
because they don't grow enough to eat.
Government subsidies,
which could be as much as 90 million
in a single year for a country,
don’t meet full demand
and are often driven
to large farms and male farmers,
even though women
are the backbone of farming in Africa.
Despite these investments,
yields per hectare haven’t increased
significantly in over four decades.
So smallholder farmers earn the bulk
of their cash at harvest time,
but then, fast-forward nine months later,
at planting time, they're cash-poor again.
The prevailing assumption
is that farmers need grants,
subsidies or credit
in order to be able
to invest in their farms.
But we found a surprising insight.
The fundamental problem
isn't that farmers have no cash.
It's that they don't have it
when they need it.
I first came across this paradox in 2008,
when I was working in microcredit.
Farmers would ask me things like,
“Can I over-repay my loan
for next year’s loan?”
or, “Hey, could I repay my loan
a year in advance?”
Even though they were using
the language of credit,
what they were actually describing
was a need to save.
But do farmers have any money to save?
Do people living
on less than two dollars a day
have any money to save?
Well, it turns out that they do,
just in very small increments.
At a local market, they might sell
a few eggs for a dollar,
or sell a goat for 10,
work on someone else's farm,
and over time, you can imagine
how that money could add up.
But many farmers live far away from banks,
so they hold that money on them,
or they hide it at home,
where it's at risk
of theft, fire, even flood.
And hey, even without those risks,
money at home is tempting.
It's hard to hold on to cash.
And sometimes, the smartest thing to do
might be to spend it.
So the real problem that farmers face
is that they lack a safe place to save.
And if they could save,
they could afford to buy what they need
to make their farms more productive
and resilient to climate change.
This is a 100-billion-dollar problem
in sub-Saharan Africa each year.
Setou, a peanut farmer in Mali,
was facing a similar challenge.
When we met in 2014,
she was feeling overwhelmed.
Climate change was hurting her harvest,
and at planting time,
she didn't even have money
to rent a cow to plow her farm,
let alone money
for improved seeds and fertilizer.
But we realized she could have saved
for what she needed
if she had a safe place to do so.
Our nonprofit, myAgro, helps farmers
in Mali, Senegal and Tanzania
save up, little by little,
for the improved seeds
and fertilizer they need.
Together, these help improve harvests
and generate a 3x return
on their investment.
Here's how the program works.
We start with a young
entrepreneur like Demba.
We equip him with a smartphone
and our app, myAgro Connect,
so that he can manage his sales territory.
At harvest time, Demba
visits farmers in his village
and asks them if they want to sign up
for a myAgro package
to improve their harvest and income.
After a farmer signs up,
they can pay slowly,
over the course of nine months.
To collect their savings payments,
we replicate the way people buy
prepaid minutes for their phone.
It's really simple --
you buy a scratch card,
scratch off the back,
and a unique code appears,
which you text in
to validate your payment.
We use the same technology to help farmers
save up for the planting period,
and because farmers are familiar
with how it works,
they trust it and use it correctly.
It's also so much more transparent
than traditional methods,
which is usually, you hand over your cash
to an agent, without any receipt.
With our platform,
we know exactly who has made a payment
and when and how much the village
entrepreneur needs to transfer to us.
A farmer can also pay directly
via mobile money, if they have it.
Farmers are able to save up
in a way that's joyful.
They often hold on to their scratch cards,
and they look at them with awe and pride
of how much they've been able
to save over time.
It's transparent,
convenient and stress-free.
Tell me, when was the last time
your bank made you that happy?
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Designing --
Designing a savings plan this way
has made it particularly easy for women.
They value the democratic access
to seeds and fertilizer,
and the savings cadence matches
the small amounts of money
they earn each week at local markets.
In a region where 20 percent of women
own a bank account,
60 percent of myAgro farmers are women.
In 2021, the average myAgro farmer
grew two times more food
than non-myAgro farmers in the same area.
This translates to 200 dollars
of additional net income.
For context, for a farmer
living on 1.50 per day,
that's a 35 percent increase.
And by expanding the purchasing power
for smallholder farmers,
the financial prospects
of young entrepreneurs like Dembe
are also improving.
Before myAgro, he was doing OK
selling goods on his own,
but now, selling seeds and fertilizer
to his community via our model,
he is thriving.
He bought two freezers
to expand his business,
and he dreams of building
a home for his family.
Last year, Dembe served
400 farmers in his village.
Using a savings-led model
has many benefits.
For the farmers,
it's reliable and low-stress.
For the organization,
it means we don't need to raise large
amounts of working capital each year.
Instead, we're unlocking capital
from farmers directly.
And by offering farmers
a trusted and transparent way
to save their own money,
they are breaking the cycle
of poverty for their families
and entering a cycle
of investment and growth.
Meanwhile,
Setou has transformed her life,
all with the power
of her own savings and farming.
In 2014, she decided to try us
and planted a quarter
of her peanut farm with us.
Each year, with her increased profits,
she reinvested a portion
in building her assets.
Today, she owns ten cows,
which she rents out to her neighbors
to earn additional income.
(Applause)
Last year, she planted her entire
one-hectare peanut farm with myAgro.
And with her profit,
she proudly moved her family
from their one-bedroom home ...
to this.
(Cheers and applause)
And now, the next generation is benefiting
from Setou’s smart farm investments.
When we get this model to scale,
it will be transformational.
Today, we serve over 100,000 farmers,
and with investments
in data and technology,
our audacious vision
is to reach one million farmers
in the next five years.
(Cheers and applause)
We believe we can harness
the power of farmers' own savings
to greatly reduce poverty
and hunger in West Africa.
Now is the time
to use a savings-led approach
to ending poverty for farmers.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)